there's a popular saying that goes if
Britney survived 2007 you can survive
today but what contributed to a republic
and private struggles and what can we
learn from her trials and tribulations
that have contributed to pop culture as
we know it today we're about to find out
[Music]
we've got a panel of pretty experts here
today ranging from die-hard stands to
people have a more complicated
relationship with a pop star we have
like a spectrum here it's like straight
to do exactly who is Britney Spears she
was born on a holy day December 2nd 1981
in Kentwood Louisiana to Jamie and Lynn
Spears at age 11 Britney is accepted
into the Mickey Mouse Club and she goes
on to sign with Jive Records and becomes
an opening act from NSYNC Britney became
a star pretty quickly in 1998 at the age
of 17 she released baby one more time
the album baby one more time became the
biggest selling LP by a teenage artist
ever I think the music video is what
made it go crazy old video was her idea
the whole like school room thing she
tied up her shirt all on her own he was
in charge of her vision from day one I
was officially a gay man I think that's
very smart but I love the way how you
said she pulled up and tied her shirt as
if she like just [ __ ] solved gravity
that was so iconic tell me you didn't
know its iconic but like people did that
before her too I mean we're still
talking about it
true true there's no argument she became
the biggest pop star in the world from
the beginning the media has always had a
fascination with Britney's sexuality in
2000 at the MTV Movie Awards Britney
ripped away a black suit to reveal a
crystal nude body suit which was
considered controversial at the time
because she was only 19 years old girl
scout moms it my grew thought she was a
bad role model she once again sparked
controversy at the 2001 VMAs when she
performed scantily clad with a Python
wrapped around her shoulders also this
huge speculation over her first public
relationship with the infamous Justin
Timberlake you guys remember their AMAs
outfit where they were dressed in all
denim right remember that
that will go with like a museum the
media was instantly infatuated with
their relationship but the fairy tale
was not meant to last Britney and Justin
broke up in 2002 it was rumored they
split because Britney was cheating and
she never directly denied these
allegations justin really wants you to
know that Britney cheated on him cry me
a river was his huge like first song
because of what Britney it was about
Britney
put this woman with blond hair gave her
that pink hat and he made it into his
first big hit and that pushed him into
pop stardom before that he was just a
member of insane I want to know what
Jessica Biel thinks about this she's too
busy running oh fudge Justin epically
stated that during their relationship
they had sex which was a big deal
considering Britney talked a lot about
her virginity there is a rule in the
book the Bible that says that I think
that is a really important game for some
reason parents wouldn't let their kids
listen to young women singing unless
they proclaim they were virgins I mean
she was a teenager
just because someone was expressing
their sexuality on stage didn't mean you
can ask such personal questions off
stage she set the mold for Disney
Channel stars and the Klaudia stars cuz
we saw Miley Cyrus kind of took the same
cycle also this time she dropped her
fourth album in the zone this is one
toxic is released every straight
person's favorite Britney song she
returned to the VMAs stage with Madonna
Christina Aguilera oh my god the kiss
actually two kisses but everyone forgets
about Monroe Steve oh my god yeah I mean
Missy Elliott was there too but who
talks about me miss it was there I was
raised Mormon so for me that was like a
little bit of a shock but you know it
spoke to me a little bit because I knew
that I was you know this queer little
boy I know it's like two women kissing
to find the adolescences of gay men
basically someone could do that in the
middle of the street now but at the time
it made her more of a new story with
Madonna as her model Britney Spears has
upset a lot of mothers in this country
really if I had an opportunity
to shoot Britney Spears I think I would
oh that's holy Shi people say it's kind
of the beginning of the downfall for
Britney in a way would you say this like
intense fascination with her public
appearance sort of is also indicative of
like celebrity and paparazzi culture at
the time period doesn't matter which
lies they ruined if they could follow
where these beers around get a good shot
of her they could you know live pretty
well for the next few months and if you
also look at her and photos during this
time period going to gas stations and
just not wearing much getting cheetos i
don't know i look at her just going to
the gas station in hugs a little
liberating for her because she's not
feeling like she has to get all gussied
up and you know being britney spears
this perfect package she's like human
behind she's okay yes following her
iconic MTV performance Britney's
personal life takes the strange Britney
marries her childhood friend Jason
Alexander in a Las Vegas wedding well it
technically never happened because it
was annulled so we got a happened the
marriage lasts 55 hours she just became
this mega mega mega star and that was
something more simple something that she
was probably nostalgic for Christian
you're getting real deep about this and
like there are a lot of things to get
real deep about how come they were drunk
in Vegas got married had it annulled and
I think that's okay to say right but
there are motive three college friends
who did the same thing I think there was
something a little more than just being
drunk to make matters worse Bernie had
to cancel her highly anticipated Onyx
Hotel Tour because she injured her knee
on a music video shoot and I think after
that I mean she hasn't really ever moved
the same way because she was such a
great dancer and that's how she was
really really really known for kind of
stuck with her to this day
yeah I know if you're like super busy
it's hard to confront your problems no
matter what they are you're not thinking
about it but for the first time she
finally had to take a pause and step
back it was kind of like a huge turning
point this brings us to another infamous
name in Brittany's life kevin federline
a 25 year old high school dropout from
Fresno California
he and his ex-girlfriend Shar Jackson
had one child together and another on
the way
Spears became enamored with the club
fixture known as meat pull me pull you
you're not attracted to that Nick no for
some reason that doesn't get my juices
flowing later that year she proposed to
Kevin Federline Britney Spears could
have had anyone on the planet but I can
see why she chose him what looks why
it's definitely a career low for her I
mean and then chaotic the show on upin
it's kind of interesting to see how we
don't love gun fights everything you
know it's just kind of there I don't
know how much some fights it shows what
does it show all the fights but you can
feel the tension on September 14 2005
Britney gave birth to her first child
Sean Preston Federline in 2006 she gave
birth to her second son with Federline
Jaden on several occasions the paparazzi
caught Britney in compromising positions
with her children Sean sitting
improperly in a baby seat and what are
the circumstances she was trying to get
away from the paparazzi she was trying
to protect her kid and it was like the
quickest way to get out of that
situation and she was being followed not
just by like one or two photographers at
a time like dozen I couldn't live under
that microscope that's what so anywhere
she couldn't go anywhere you did we just
need privacy and we need our respect and
those are things that you have to have
as a human
if someone's following you 24/7 are you
gonna be perfect 24/7
absolutely not media speculation about
her parenting resulted in the LA
Department of Child and Family Services
to investigate her Britney broke up with
Kevin Federline after two years of
marriage she was a rapper right Oh God
never just a white guy in cornrows was
the first the first song was called
Papa's ow oh my god I remember yes
following the announcement of her
divorce Britney is seen partying it up
with none other than Paris Hilton and
Lindsay Lohan yeah this was the start of
Britney's excessive partying she is
under the influence of alcohol and you
don't know what else is going on there
are these famous images of her exiting
the car with her hoo-ha showing to the
world that point there was nothing she
could do that was off-limits to anyone
in February
Hollywood com reports that an email from
her assistant says that Britney was
spiraling out of control and her family
wanted her to get treatment Britney
Spears checked into rehab and left in
less than 24 hours Britney went to a
hair salon in Tarzana California she was
reportedly complaining about her hair
extensions being too tight the salon
owner refused to cut her hair so Britney
grabbed the Clippers and she did it
herself
we saw photos every moment of this whole
weekend was heavily documented I know
there's like conspiracies as to why she
did it
but like she said she was tired of
everyone touching her you know she was
constantly told what to do and pulled
and pushed and I think it was her kind
of liberating herself in a way like I'm
shaving my head that Britney is gone our
first thought when we were seeing this
say Oh Britney so crazy yeah like at the
time I didn't understand the whole
mental health aspect about it I don't
think any of us really did and so she
just became the butt of the joke
I don't think it came as a surprise to
anyone because that's where we were
pushing her in September 2007 a judge
ordered Britney Spears to submit to
random drug tests in October 2007
Federline is awarded sole custody of the
case
and beers visitation rights with her
children were also suspended until she
complied with court orders in their
custody battle after she was asked how
she was doing these beers was filmed
telling reporters quote eat it snort it
lick it bucket and she's also speaking
in a British accent to paparazzi at this
time in the midst of all this personal
drama Britney's team strong-armed her
into performing at the VMAs
obviously the performance of someone who
was struggling with a lot of stuff for
the performance she had to wear a wig
because her hair was still growing back
she stayed out until 2:30 a.m. that
night
forgettin you know appearance cuz people
have made comments about her not being
in peak shape she looked downright out
of it was she ever going to win over the
general public at that point I mean we
were in the middle of lighting her on
fire you know they wanted that to happen
despite all these personal struggles in
2007 Britney manages to release quite
possibly her best album yet black out a
piece of light in a very dark dark time
I think after seeing headline after
headline being like her careers over her
careers over her fans were over her she
still releases a good body of work it
was her only album to join the archives
of the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame after
black outs released Britney Spears was
hospitalized after locking herself in
the bathroom with her youngest son Jaden
for three hours and refusing to hand him
over to her ex-husband Kevin Federline
later in the month
Britney Spears is hospitalized again and
a motorcade of police vehicles and a
police helicopter took her in an
ambulance at 1:00 a.m. her mother also
encouraged dr. Phil to visit Britney in
the psychiatric ward of cedars-sinai
Medical Center at this time dr. Phil
immediately went around and told the
press everything 2008 Britney Spears
begins being controlled by a
guardianship a court approved
conservatorship for people who are
deemed incapable of taking care of
themselves this is like a major turning
point in her life I think why she
committed to the conservatorship was so
she could have some custody of her kids
so she could see her kids all she cared
about was her children there's a lot of
good things that can come out of
structure and some certain limits she
kind of like went into hiding a bit you
didn't see her everywhere you didn't see
all these Britney controversies it gets
sticky when you think about her dad and
the money he makes from being a
conservator
she's being forced into a studio at
gunpoint we have no idea and there
perming her up for this huge comeback at
the 2008 VMAs a year after that give me
more performance wasn't really only a
year only a year was it too soon for her
hopefully their cycle just doesn't
repeat itself where she feels like too
many people around her and controlling
her if what happened in Britney's career
in 2007 happened today in 2018 how would
it play out differently for way more
empathetic to issues surrounding mental
health I will say that sometimes I feel
like people still haven't even learned
this because if you look at Amanda Bynes
and her time there was the same exact
process none of us want to be watched
like that so I don't understand why you
can watch them and laugh at them but I'm
gonna go mess up in private because I
have that ability to do you guys think
we've made any progress in the way that
media treats and portrays women's bodies
and sexuality now we're in a place where
we're talking about it and you know
people are admitting things and being
vocal I see as time goes on we're kind
of like reclaiming our sexuality and
trying to figure out you know what it
means to be a woman I think we can
describe Brittany as a trailblazer she
could have just crawled back to
Louisiana you would be talking about
like whatever happened to Britney Spears
but the mere fact that she came back and
stronger than ever is pretty impressive
before her Vegas was kind of seen as
like you're getting a little older as an
artist have a Vegas residency that's
some good money in your last year's
Britney turn that into you can go while
you're still the young artist you are
make good money people will come see you
from all around the world and now look
everyone's coming to Vegas yeah she is a
trailblazer so it's exciting to see
she's only 35 36 which i think is the
age that you qualify to run for
president of the United States I I can't
handle that
[Music]